parler de la réforme des retraites
évidemment le gouvernement n'arrive pas
à convaincre les syndicats ont entamé la
mobilisation avant la journée de mardi
les oppositions elles ont entamé la
bataille parlementaire Marion delpechi
les plus près les femmes les personnes
qui ont les boulots les plus pénis la
CGT énergie avait promis de bloquer les
raffineries et pores pour 48 heures mais
hier soir le mouvement était suspendu
les grévistes veulent se préserver pour
la grève nationale prévue le 31 janvier
à l'appel de tous les syndicats nous
savons y compris qu'il y a besoin
d'impacter concrètement l'économie
puisque nous avons le gouvernement qui
est toujours dans la finance et qui ne
comprennent peu quand on le fera pas là
où Jean ferba c'est-à-dire au niveau du
porte-monnaie il y a besoin entre ces
journées d'actions professionnelles de
structurer le mouvement sur
une forme de permanence qui permet à
chacun à partir des moyens qu'il a de
s'inscrire dans la durée à Paris hier
soir quelques manifestants défilés au
flambeau alors que les oppositions
préparaient-elles à l'Assemblée
nationale la bataille parlementaire plus
de 7000 amendements ont été déposés en
vue de l'examen en commission
majoritairement concentré sur l'article
7 du projet de loi pour s'opposer au
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite si la France insoumise n'a pas
reproduit sa stratégie d'obstruction
massive de 2020 les députés de la
coalition de gauche Nupe en ont tout de
même déposé plus de 5000 de quoi
compromettre la possibilité pour les
députés d'aller au bout du texte dans
les délais impartis car les échanges
dans l'hémicycle doivent démarrer le 6
février et s'achever le 17 à minuit pour
que le texte passe ensuite au Sénat
et on va évidemment parler de la
bataille parlementaire dans quelques
instants mais d'abord on le voit
Jean-Daniel un les syndicats pour suivre
leur mobilisation rappelle qu'il y a eu
plus d'un million de personnes dans la
rue il y a une semaine est-ce que le
gouvernement a perdu la bataille de
l'opinion oui mais la question c'est à
un moment gagné quand vous prenez ne
serait-ce que la dernière élection
présidentielle on se rappelle que ça
avait été quasiment la seule mesure qui
avait été identifiée de la part du
candidat et Emmanuel Macron à la
présidentielle alors à l'époque on
parlait de retraite à 65 ans et pas
forcément d'ailleurs de tout ce que
pouvait être les aménagements ou les
compensations à caractère social quand
vous regardez uniquement l'électorat
d'Emmanuel Macron la motivation de vote
autour de la question des retraites se
situait en septième position alors même
que ceux qui avaient voté d'un côté pour
Marine Le Pen ou de l'autre pour
Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'était la troisième
position évidemment pas sur ce que vous
pouvez dire le candidat pour lequel ils
avaient été annaboter mais déjà à
l'époque contre la proposition qui était
portée de la part d'Emmanuel Macron donc
ça c'était le premier aspect le deuxième
aspect de manière un peu structurelle
qui est important d'avoir à l'esprit
tout ce qui est à l'avant sur l'urgence
à agir sur le fait qu'il y aurait des
déficits qui pourraient être amenés à
venir notre système qui pourrait être
potentiellement en danger quand vous
interrogez pas uniquement sur la
question des retraites mais sur
l'urgence à agir en France sur la
question de la dette et des déficits
c'était la deuxième motivation de vote
des Français en 2012 à l'époque où
François Hollande a été élu président
de vote en 2017 et là au cours de cette
dernière élection présidentielle la 18e
motivation de vote des Français donc la
période quoi qu'il en coûte à modifier
fondamentalement le regard des Français
sur l'urgence à agir d'une manière
générale je parle pas que la question
des retraites mais sur tout ce que
pouvait être nos dettes nos déficit quel
que soit en fait les types de dettes ou
de déficit qui pouvaient être amenés à
opérer et donc dans ce contexte là le
point de départ qui est porté de la part
de l'exécutif en disant il faut agir
autrement vous verrez dans quelques
années nous aurons des difficultés n'a
pas été initialement entendu de la part
de ça veut dire Benjamin c'est on écoute
Jordan que le quoi qu'il en coûte
politiquement est en train de se
retourner contre l'exécutif dans cette
bataille pour la réforme des retraites
qui a été dit il rend cette réforme
difficilement justifiable les impératifs
qui auraient pu être mis en avant y
compris auprès d'une partie de
l'électorat de droite aujourd'hui sont
beaucoup beaucoup moins audibles il faut
rajouter que vous avez une opinion qui
s'est un peu cristallisé contre non pas
cette réforme parce que la réforme de
2019-2020 n'était pas la même mais
contre l'idée d'une réforme des
retraites de manière assez précoce on
voit des enquêtes à l'été 2019 qui
montre que à ce moment-là on a une forme
de stabilisation contre l'idée d'une
réforme avec pour principe si jamais
elle a lieu et bien je serai un peu le
dindon de la face j'en serais perdant et
donc ce faisant aujourd'hui arriva à
retourner cette opinion apparaît assez
compliqué et le gouvernement ne laissait
même pas en réalité il tente de calmer
le jeu on a eu très très tôt ce qui peut
paraître assez étrange d'un point de vue
stratégiquement une un gouvernement qui
a cédé sur la mesure d'âge en passant de
65 à 64 tu aurais pu être un élément de
négociation l'idée était simple en
réalité c'était un il fallait faire des
concessions à LR pour être certain que
le texte passe et que le texte passe
vite parce qu'une mobilisation sociale
en règle générale s'épuise et ses
souffles une fois que le texte est voté
d'où la volonté en y reviendra de
compresser la procédure et de l'autre
côté et bien espérons en renonçant 65
ans ont des mobilise un petit peu ça au
moins ça pas marché parce que c'est un
peu ce que dit l'exécutif Jean-Daniel
hein il dit mais on a déjà fait des
concessions on avait promis 65 ans
finalement on est à 64 on a pris des
mesures pour les retraités actuels pour
leur pension minimum ça ça ne passe pas
ce sont des messages qui ne passent pas
dans l'opinion il y a deux aspects
différents le premier aspect c'est que
déjà quand vous vendez aux Français dans
le cadre d'une enquête qu'on a réalisé
par exemple pour RTL et AEF est-ce que
ils sont d'accord ou pas sur le principe
du décalage de l'âge légal de départ à
la retraite on n'entre même pas dans les
différentes modalités vous avez près de
70% des Français qui déclarent qui sont
opposés aux principes même donc on entre
même pas pour savoir est-ce que c'est 63
64 ou 65 ans dès qu'on entre dans le
détail on voit bien qu'évidemment le
regard à l'égard de 65 ans ou 64 ans est
quand même assez critiqué de la part de
nos compatriotes ça c'est le premier
aspect puis le deuxième aspect toutes
les dimensions de compensation que vous
avez évoqué sont-elles ne serait-ce que
entendues de la part des Français la
réponse est non quant aux leur pose la
question est-ce que vous êtes favorable
au fait qu'il puisse y avoir une
augmentation des de la pension minimale
à 1200 euros la réponse est oui est-ce
que vous êtes favorable au fait qu'on
puisse tenir compte des carrières
longues voire même d'une dimension dont
on parle quand même peu mais du fait qui
est la fin à terme des régimes spéciaux
la réponse est oui de manière absolument
certaine est-ce qu'ils vont l'évoquer
spontanément les Français lorsque les
interroge sur la réforme des retraites
la réponse est non est-ce qu'ils vont
considérer en fait que tout ce pack qui
est un pack en gros de modification de
dimension un caractère social ou ceci
étal peut être de nature à les faire
accepter d'autres modalités la réponse
est non plus et je pense qu'il est
important c'est pour ça que j'assistais
là dessus tout à l'heure c'est que
puisse rappeler les conditions du débat
telles qu'elles ont été portées dans le
cadre de l'élection présidentielle et au
moment de l'élection présidentielle on
n'a pas parlé en fait de réflexion
autour du travail des seniors autour en
fait de la nécessité de pouvoir
retourner au plein d'emploi de la
nécessité de sauvegarder notre site pas
du tout on a entendu l'erreur originale
c'était Emmanuel Macron qui a dit la
réforme des retraites c'est le report de
l'âge à 65
de dire que d'un point de vue d'opinion
il y a une cristallisation initiale dès
le mois de mars de l'année dernière
autour de la question pour ou contre la
réforme la retraite à 650 et que dans ce
contexte là vous avez un débat qui s'est
focalisé autour de l'âge légal de départ
à la retraite et que toutes les
dimensions complémentaires ne sont pas
venues se substituer non seulement comme
on l'a indiqué tout à l'heure parce que
la question de l'urgence à agir
n'apparaît pas comme étant absolument
essentielle mais également parce qu'on
n'a pas eu un débat qui s'est focalisé
autour de comment faire entre guillemets
pour mieux travailler jusqu'à 64 ans
dans la cité française Benjamin
ça ça part de là ça part de la campagne
présidentielle en fait il y a eu une
erreur de méthode du gouvernement qui a
qui a concentré cette réforme des
retraites autour du report de l'âge dans
le début je dirais il y a une erreur
d'appréciation on entend beaucoup ces
derniers temps est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron
est légitime ou pas à faire cette
réforme d'un point de vue juridique
c'est intéressant parce qu'en réalité le
président a pas de compétences à pas de
pouvoir pour faire voter une loi donc
dire que lorsque vous votez pour un
président vous le l'Élysée sur un
programme législatif déjà c'est faux
c'est à dire que vous êtes un peu flou à
l'élection par tous les candidats qui
vous propose en réalité des programmes
législatifs et pas des programmes
présidentiels donc ensuite ils ont pas
de majorité pour voter la réforme et
bien par définition c'est le vote au
législatives qui entraîne ensuite là le
blanc saint donnait un programme quel
qu'il soit de l'autre côté et bien vous
avez un vote qui en effet ne s'est pas
cristallisé ni sur cette réforme ni sur
une adhésion au projet donc là on est
dans le discours politique ce discours
politique et bien il conduit à dire pour
Emmanuel Macron à dire je peux y aller
je peux foncer mais la réalité et bien
vous avez là une distance qui se creuse
et avec l'opinion et avec les capacités
réelles d'agir qui font que un moment ça
a chope et on en est un peu là on va
parler de la bataille parlementaire
puisque évidemment tout ça est lié le
texte arrive en commission la semaine
prochaine à l'Assemblée nationale on
connaît déjà le nom d'amendements 7000
on va en parler mais d'abord on va
parler de la méthode choisie par
l'exécutif pour aborder ce débat au
Parlement Audrey après le 47,3 après le
49-3 pardon c'est donc le 47 ans on s'y
perd de la Constitution qui se retrouve
au coeur des débats dans cette réforme
des retrait bah oui Oriane mais vous
avez raison on venait à peine de saisir
les contours du 49-3 qui permet au
gouvernement de passer un texte en force
et voilà qu'on nous parle du 47 ans un
article un peu méconnu de la
Constitution c'est donc normal de se
mélanger les pinceaux qui pointent le
bout de son nez pourquoi il nous
intéresse je vais tenter de vous
expliquer sous le contrôle de Benjamin
Morel qui me scrute la pression du début
le gouvernement a choisi de faire passer
la réforme par la voix d'un projet de
loi de finance rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale c'est compliqué mais ça
veut dire que c'est un texte budgétaire
et ce n'est pas un texte traditionnel et
ça permet d'utiliser le 49-3 je dirais à
volonté le 493 qu'on connaît lui il n'y
a pas de limite sur les textes
budgétaires et ça permet aussi au
gouvernement de ne pas sacrifier de
cartouche comme pour un projet de loi
traditionnel mais en faisant de la sorte
on déclenche le 47,1 et lui c'est un
article chronomètre couperait son but
c'est d'éviter que les débats autour du
budget ne s'éternisent pour cette
réforme le Parlement disposera donc de
50 jours pour débattre dont seulement 20
à la en première lecture à l'Assemblée
pas SSD le gouvernement saisit le Sénat
qui doit statuer dans un délai de 15
jours la navette continue comme cela
avant que tout se termine le 26 mars à
minuit pas une minute de plus je peux
penser que c'est assez brutal pour Bruno
Retailleau le patron des républicains ce
n'est pas un problème écoutez
on a une constitution d'un cinquième
république ma filiation égoïste donc ces
institutions me vont très bien j'observe
que même avec le 47 ans le temps que
dont disposera l'Assemblée pour discuter
du texte est un temps qui sera même plus
important que celui qu'elle avait dont
elle avait disposé sur un texte plus
classique pour la réforme de 2010 alors
il n'empêche sur le papier si le
Parlement ne parvient pas à boucler dans
un délai de 50 jours les dispositions de
loi sur le papier peuvent être mises en
oeuvre par ordonnance Benjamin Morel
vous avez peut-être une précision
justement sur sur ces ordonnances c'est
obligatoire il faut bien voir que alors
il y a plusieurs éléments d'abord cette
cet article pour la petite anecdote il a
été introduit par Alain Juppé en 1996
donc on voit à peu près l'affiliation et
entre guillemets ce qui ce qui peut un
advenir non mais plus sérieusement on a
là à faire un article qui en réalité a
été créé et pensée en copier-coller de
l'article 47 sur les lois de finances
l'objectif il est où il est de dire
grosso modo et bien au 1er janvier il
faut qu'il y ait un budget parce que si
on un budget je te donne à l'américaine
ou bien gouvernement qui se dit j'ai pas
de majorité je suis contraint de
démissionner c'est comme ça qu'on
instaure la responsabilité du
Gouvernement devant le Parlement
historiquement dès la restauration en
disant bah voilà pas de budget on peut
pas payer les fonctionnaires on peut pas
prélever l'impôt pour un PLFSS on peut
pas verser les pensions donc le
gouvernement est contraint à
démissionner sous la Cinquième
République on essaie d'éviter ça donc si
jamais vous ne rentrez pas dans le cadre
des 50 jours et bien ensuite on exécute
le budget par ordonnance mais parce
qu'il y a urgence parce qu'il y a le 1er
janvier et donc là on a un problème qui
se pose parce que sur ce projet de loi
retraite il n'y a pas d'urgence si les
voté en avril s'il est voté en mai si
les voté en juin et ben ça pose pas de
problème en termes de versement des
pensions on va pas avoir un régime des
retraites qui va s'effondrer alors on
sait que sur les projets loi de
financement rectificatif on peut quand
même appliquer ce type de délai mais
parce qu'on considère que tout d'un coup
il y a un déséquilibre rapide dans le
budget et que donc il faut le traiter
vite là encore une fois il y a pas
d'urgence donc ce que l'on voit
actuellement et si on prend notamment
l'interview de Laurent FA dans le Canard
Enchaîné dit il y a deux semaines à
l'interview qu'il n'en est pas vraiment
une mais qui est entre guillemets et qui
n'a pas été contredit par le Conseil
constitutionnel qu'est-ce qu'il dit il
dit en réalité il va falloir faire
attention à deux choses en soi vous
pouvez utiliser ce véhicule législatif
mais il y a deux conditions la première
condition c'est qu'on est dans le cadre
d'un PLFSS et on met pas tout dans un
PLFSS mais pas notamment ce qu'on
appelle des cavaliers sociaux c'est
cavaliers sociaux ce sont et bien des
amendements ou des dispositions qui
n'ont pas avoir directement avec le
financement des régimes sociaux et donc
tout ce qui relève et le pointe
nommément de la pénibilité ou de l'index
senior cavaliers donc ça pourra pas être
dans le texte et si ça y est et bien ça
risquera d'être de passer sous les
mitraille du Conseil constitutionnel il
faut que le gouvernement trouve un moyen
soit il passe par voie réglementaire
soit il passe par un autre projet de loi
mais évidemment quand vous êtes sorti de
la bataille des retraites et que vous
relancez un projet de loi bon courage
par ailleurs l'opposition pourraient
vouloir réintroduire une mesure d'âge
donc on repart pour un tour le deuxième
la deuxième chose que dit le rend Fabius
c'est ok il y a des délais ces délais il
faut voir que 20 jours à l'Assemblée
qu'un jour au Sénat le gouvernement
n'est pas tout à fait tenu de les
respecter il peut faire comme s'il ne
les avait pas vu il peut faire traîner
un tout petit peu le débat mais
néanmoins s'il fait ça comme il a pas
déclenché d'autres dispositions qui lui
permettent de juguler l'obstruction
notamment ce qu'on appelle le temps
législatif programmé à l'Assemblée
nationale ça veut dire qu'il est tout nu
devant l'obstruction et que si jamais il
y a une obstruction massive il doit
attendre il doit attendre il doit
attendre jusqu'à ce que le texte soit
finalement voté soit il utilise le 49
aliné à 3 parce que ce que dit l'eau en
Fabius grosso modo c'est il faut qu'il y
ait un vote à l'Assemblée nationale en
première lecture on peut pas vous
contenter au bout de 20 jours de dire
c'est fini mais mesdames messieurs on
passe au Sénat il faut qu'il y ait un
vote donc soit vous attendez la fin de
l'obstruction soit vous utilisez le 49
alinés à trois qui est du point de vue
de la procédure parlementaire la seule
façon de déclencher un vote n'importe
quand dans l'examen d'un texte et c'est
ça qui est intéressant Oriane c'est
toute la communication du gouvernement
sur les mesures sociales en fait c'est
pas forcément sûr que ça
c'est même très peu sûr que sa figure
dans le texte puisque les amendements ne
pourront pas être déposés en ce sens et
Olivier de sobre qui était auditionné au
Sénat expliquer on fera peut-être passer
ces points par décret donc ça évidemment
ça sa questionne les sénateurs ont posé
beaucoup de questions là-dessus et donc
toute la communication faite
actuellement sur ces mesures sociales
qui compenseraient le recul du départ en
retraite en fait ce sera peut-être pas
dans le texte ça pose un problème ça
passe par décrire rapidement parce qu'en
fait déjà c'est un tiens vaut mieux que
deux tu l'auras et donc pour les
parlementaires qui vont s'engager à
voter le texte l'idée que les mesures
seraient prises après ça peut être un
tantinet problématique et si vous
modifiez quelque chose par décret vous
pouvez le remodifier derrière par des
crises c'est à dire qu'il n'y a pas la
certitude que ça reste dans la loi et
que le législateur sera à nouveau
consulté si on veut revenir dessus
Jean-Daniel est-ce que opinion est
sensible à tout ça est-ce que la manière
dont le gouvernement présente ce texte
au Parlement le véhicule législatif
utilisé le fait qu'il y a un temps
contraint est-ce que ça imprime dans
l'opinion ou est-ce qu'on peut importe
finalement regarde juste la mesure d'âge
alors est-ce qu'il regarde avec autant
de précision l'ensemble de la mécanique
la réponse est non est-ce que pour
autant ça les empêche d'avoir une
opinion est-ce que ça les empêche en
fait de juger sur la méthode la réponse
est oui et donc c'est la dimension de la
méthode est absolument essentielle c'est
que est-ce qu'on a le sentiment ou pas
au final qui aura une forme de passage
en force et ça sera quasiment le seul
aspect qui peut qui peut jouer une des
questions
49-3 ou éventuellement le sentiment que
tu aurais une forme de vol bloqué d'une
manière d'une autre quel que soit les
conditions qui soient qui soit opérées
un des reproches qui souvent est
effectué à l'égard du gouvernement c'est
un gouvernement qui n'écoute pas un
gouvernement qui ne consulte pas et un
gouvernement qui ne tient pas compte des
avis divers qui peut être lui être émis
et là le fait qu'on soit dans une
configuration en dehors de l'Assemblée
nationale où vous avez une union
syndicale où il y a des revendications
qui apparaissent comme étant en tout cas
jusqu'à présent relativement clair un
point où autour notamment de non au
changement de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite qui fait une union entre les
différentes confédérations syndicales et
ce qu'on entend d'une manière générale
lorsque on regarde ce que disent les
manifestants lorsqu'ils se déplacent
dans la rue ou lorsqu'on écoute les
Français lorsque les interroge à travers
différentes enquêtes d'opinion c'est que
il y a la perception que oui on dit
quelque chose il y a une majorité très
nette d'un point de vue d'opinion qui se
manifeste il y a des personnes qui
descendent dans la rue il y a des grèves
qui sont organisent autour globalement
du même du même motif donc on a cette
forme de d'attention de la part des
Français en disant on veut vraiment être
certain que vous ayez entendu le message
il y a un point malgré tout sur lequel
je pense qu'il est important de revenir
on verra ce qui se passera dans les
semaines à venir mais que par rapport à
1995 il y a quand même une forme de
singularité c'est à dire qu'en 1995 à
aucun moment Jacques Chirac avait
indiqué qui avait urgence à agir
concernant nos différents comptes
sociaux pour aller assez rapidement et
donc il y a eu le sentiment d'une forme
de trahison cette forme de trahison
s'est traduite non seulement par une
mobilisation sociale mais également
c'est pas le seul élément mais pas la
défaite aux élections législatives de
1997 là aujourd'hui je dis pas forcément
qu'il y a une légitimité complète qui a
été apportée à Emmanuel Macron à travers
le vote à l'élection présidentielle mais
on peut pas lui faire le procès en
trahison c'est à dire qu'il avait
annoncé la couleur si on peut monter
l'expression très clairement
initialement il y a quand même une
partie je parle pas en fait uniquement
des parlementaires mais également de
l'opinion c'est à dire ceux qui ont voté
pour Emmanuel Macron et ceux qui situent
à droite sur l'échiquier politique qui
sont un peu en soutien les gars de la
réforme en disant que d'une manière eux
sont sensibles aux différents arguments
du gouvernement donc il est loin d'être
majoritaire mais pour autant d'un point
de vue de segment électoraux qui sont
aujourd'hui stratégiques qui se
manifeste pas complètement d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée nationale mais en tout cas
qui d'un point de vue d'opinion sont
stratégique vous interrogez les
électeurs et les réalisent oui il faut
aller à la retraite à 74 vous interrogez
les électeurs qui ont voté pour Emmanuel
Macron ils vont vous dire oui il faut la
retraite à 64 ans et donc qui vont
mettre une forme de pression à l'heure
actuelle en tout cas de soutien à
l'égard de l'exécutif dans son
entreprise
les amendements qui ont été déposés
on l'a vu l'amendement sans grande
surprise environ 6000 viennent de la
Nupe et alors ce qui est peut-être plus
une surprise c'est qu'il y en a très peu
du rassemblement national moins de 100
c'était étonnant ou pas c'est pas
forcément étonnant c'est pas un groupe
qui a une tradition d'obstruction
d'abord c'est pas un groupe qui a une
tradition parce que c'est un groupe
assez nouveau il y avait pas eu de
précédents groupe à Rennes sauf en 86 88
donc c'est un groupe qui en réalité
aujourd'hui tente de passer un peu entre
les gouttes il essaie de montrer qu'il
est responsable et pour être responsable
il ne rentre pas dans une stratégie
d'obstruction et quand même temps il
s'oppose et pour s'opposer et bien il
votera des amendements de la nuque et il
ne votera pas le texte donc on est un
petit peu dans cette position entre deux
responsable donc pas obstructeur mais en
même temps opposé et donc dans
l'opposition plus clairement que LR donc
votre compte c'est plutôt la stratégie
du RL en termes de communication et pour
lui aujourd'hui c'est probablement
plutôt la bonne Jean-Daniel pour
terminer à quel profite cette bataille
de l'opposition rassemblement nationale
ou à la nuque à la France il faut
attendre la fin du de la fin de la loi
pour pouvoir le dire quoi qu'il en soit
ce qui est intéressant on a réalisé une
grande enquête pour pour sciences
publiques d'observatoire du Parlement ce
que l'on peut voir c'est que le premier
groupe qui apparaît comme étant
d'opposition aux yeux des Français quel
que soit l'orientation politique des
personnes que nous avons été amenées
interrogées c'est le rassemblement
national alors même que si on allume la
télévision on peut avoir le sentiment
que c'est plus la nuque qui est d'une
manière globale cherche à animer les
débats si je peux utiliser cette
expression là et puis le deuxième aspect
même en termes de confiance ou de
jugement à l'égard de l'action des
parlementaires à l'heure actuelle il y a
un jugement de la part des Français
Encore une fois quel que soit leur
position politique qui est nettement
plus en appréciation de la posture qui
est adoptée de la part du rassemblement
national que de la part de la nuque à
l'heure actuelle donc il y a
tendentiellement une stratégie en tout
cas jusqu'à présent qui apparaît comme
étant d'un point de vue d'opinion plus
opérante pour le rassemblement national
que pour la nuque ça se traduit même en
point de vue d'opinion que quand vous
regardez les différents enquêtes la
deuxième personnalité à laquelle les
Français accorde le plus leur confiance
[Musique]